mesdames messieurs bonjour à toutes et à
tous une large part de ce conseil des
ministres a été consacrée naturellement
à la situation sanitaire il ya deux ans
presque jour pour jour la france
recensait les deux premiers cas de
coville sur son territoire il y a deux
ans presque jour pour jour nous
installions la cellule de crise qui est
encore en vigueur aujourd'hui et depuis
deux ans nous avons affronter
l'impensable avec solidité et solidarité
nous l'avons fait grâce aux efforts
extraordinaires de nos personnels de
santé et grâce à des français
responsable et exemplaire nous avons
surtout appris en deux ans à vivre
chaque jour un peu mieux avec ce virus
nous faisons grâce aux progrès de la
science aaas à la vaccination et grâce
au pass sanitaire puis vaccinale qui
nous ont permis de laisser le pays
ouvert aujourd'hui l'épidémie a
clairement changé de nature nous avons
connu ces dernières semaines deux vagues
vous le savez superposer une vague delta
particulièrement dangereuse que nous
avons surmonté grâce à la vaccination et
aux passes sanitaire une vague omicron
fulgurante impressionnante que nous
affrontons encore grâce aux appels aux
passes et à la responsabilité des
français
désormais nous sommes en train de
vaincre la vague delta qui continue son
très net reflux ne représente plus que 2
% des contaminations et parce que ce
variant est bien plus sévère son recul
explique aussi la baisse de pression que
nous observons dans nos services de
réanimation depuis maintenant plusieurs
jours une baisse qui est lente mais
qu'ils aient continué donc rassurante en
revanche la vague omicron circulent
toujours à une vitesse effrénée tous les
départements de métropole voient leur
taux d'incidence dépasser 2000 plus de
trois cent soixante mille cas en moyenne
par jour sont toujours recensés dans
notre pays avec heureusement une
proportion de formes graves bien plus
faible qu'avant omicron continue à
gagner du terrain et nous ne sommes pas
encore au pic cependant je l' ai dit à
plusieurs reprises à ce pupitre depuis
maintenant de longs et le président du
conseil scientifique l'a rappelé hier
dans une émission de télévision avec ce
variant plus encore qu'avant le nombre
de contaminations devient un indicateur
moins révélateur de la dangerosité et de
l'impact de l'épidémie c'est donc bien
sur l'hôpital que nos yeux sont rivés et
la vague omicron il sévit encore le
nombre d'hospitalisations or et
animations continuent de croître et
dépasse les 30 mille personnes
hospitalisées un chiffre qui n'avait pas
été atteint depuis longtemps
alors ce que nous disent les
scientifiques ce que nous montrent les
chiffres ce qui augure la baisse des cas
en ile de france c'est que nous pouvons
espérer voir reculer l'épidémie dans les
semaines qui viennent c'est surtout que
l'épidémie a changé de visage le disait
et que les scientifiques nous disent que
notre hôpital devrait tenir notre espoir
est renforcée aussi par le pass
vaccinale validée par le conseil
constitutionnel est entrée en vigueur
depuis ce lundi le pass daksi na l'a
déjà montré des résultats je le rappelle
en poussant plus d'un million de
français à faire leurs premières doses
de vaccin avant même que le pass
vaccinale ne s'applique depuis son
entrée en vigueur il prend sa deuxième
casquette celle de la protection il nous
permet de prévoir la levée des rares
restrictions encore en vigueur dans les
lieux qui sont soumis notre espoir enfin
c'est la vaccination qui continuent de
progresser près de 54 millions de
français reçus désormais au moins une
injection et 34 millions de français ont
reçu leur dose de rappel et nous lançons
de nouveaux un appel à tous ceux dont la
deuxième dose date d'il ya plus de
quatre mois qu'ils n'ont pas été
contaminés depuis faites vous vacciner
avant l'échéance du 15 février nous
avons donc de bonnes nouvelles nous
avons des boucliers solide et nous avons
dans la dynamique épidémique des motifs
d'espoir en conséquence comme nous
l'avons toujours fait nous pouvons lever
les ultimes restrictions qui était
encore nécessaire pour protéger nos
hôpitaux c'est le sens du calendrier en
deux étapes annoncées la semaine
dernière par le premier ministre et par
le ministre des solidarités et de la
santé nous pourrons ainsi dans une
semaine le 2 février lever les jauges
encore en vigueur et mettre fin au
télétravail au but à toi nous pourrons
ensuite le 16 février rouvrir les
discothèques partout dans le pays et
lever les restrictions qui pèsent
aujourd'hui sur les barres vous le voyez
nous tenons notre cap qui est de faire
peser des contraintes minimal sur
l'ensemble des français singulièrement
sur ceux qui ont fait le choix en
responsabilité de se faire vacciner pour
cela nous prenons à chaque instant les
décisions nécessaires pour maximiser la
protection et minimiser les restrictions
dans notre pays ces décisions ont permis
d'accroître notre couverture vaccinale
est de garder notre pays ouvert elles
ont permis à notre hôpital de tenir
malgré la déferlante omicron ces
dernières semaines et aujourd'hui nous
pouvons donc avancer avec prudence bien
sûr mais aussi avec optimisme lors de ce
conseil des ministres nous sommes
également revenus sur la nécessité de
continuer à travailler à agir à protéger
cette semaine les prix du carburant sont
repartis à la hausse et tout comme nous
avions annoncé un bouclier tarifaire je
le rappelle pour limiter la hausse des
prix du gaz pour limiter la hausse des
prix de l'électricité décidée d'un
chèque énergie exceptionnelle de 100
euros à la fin de l'année 2021 pour 6
millions de ménages décidé d'une
indemnité inflation versé à 38 millions
de français nous prenons aujourd'hui des
mesures pour aider les français qui
travaillent qui utilisent
quotidiennement dans le cadre de leur
travail leur voiture face à la hausse
des prix du carburant aussi pour
accompagner ceux dont la voiture est un
outil de travail majeurs le premier
ministre a annoncé hier que le barème
des indemnités kilométriques serait
relevé de 10% c'est une aide efficace
c'est une aide concrète pour les
personnes encore une fois dépendante de
leur véhicule pour travailler qui
permettra une économie moyenne de 150
euros par bénéficiaire
une fois de plus je le dis nous visons
l'efficacité nous visons des aides
ciblées et concrètes plutôt que les
effets d'annoncé les mesures qui
seraient inefficaces pour le porte
monnaie des français et coûteuse pour
les finances publiques dans le même
temps et puisque nous parlons des sujets
économiques et sociaux je veux insister
sur le fait que le redressement de notre
économie et de l'emploi se confirme au
quatrième trimestre le nombre de
demandeurs emploi a diminué de 5 9% sur
un an ce sont 12 6 % de chômeurs en
moins c'est cinq cent mille personnes
sans aucune activité en moins notre taux
de chômage est au plus bas depuis près
de 15 ans et le taux d'emploi est au
plus haut depuis 1975 dans notre pays
nous continuons donc à enrayer le
chômage de masse et à travailler
investir pour l'activité pour l'emploi
dans notre pays mesdames messieurs ce
conseil des ministres a également été
l'occasion d'examiner plusieurs textes
et je veux commencer par l'un d'entre
eux qui vous intéressera
particulièrement le conseil des
ministres ce matin a adopté le décret de
convocation des électeurs pour
l'élection présidentielle les échéances
où vous les connaissez elles sont
désormais actés le processus
démocratique et lancez vous connaissez
les dates ce que permet ce décret c'est
évidemment de fixer précisément les
dates dans le marbre du texte
réglementaire c'est donc bien les 10 et
24 avril ce que permet ce décret aussi
c'est de démarrer la procédure de
collecte des parrainages qui démarreront
qu'il démarre donc ces jours ci et qui
courra jusqu'au 4 mars et ce décret
permet également au garde des sceaux
d'installer la commission nationale de
contrôle de la campagne présidentielle
qui sera donc installé ce vendredi
ensuite le ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères a présenté deux
projets de loi approuvant des accords le
premier accord permet aux états membres
de la commission de l'océan indien de
renforcer leur coopération régionale en
faveur de la sécurité environnementale
et maritimes mais aussi dans le domaine
de la santé le second accord permet de
mettre en place un mécanisme d'échangé
de partage de l'information maritime
dans cette même région toujours à des
fins de sécurité maritime venait ensuite
une ordonnance relative à la gestion du
fonds européen agricole pour le
développement rural une part importante
de la gestion de ce four reviendra
désormais aux régions et des moyens
adaptés selon leur seront donc
transférés pour cela nous avons
également entendu deux communications de
la ministre de la transformation et de
la fonction publique elle a tout d'abord
présenté l'accord unanime signé
aujourd'hui avec tous les syndicats de
la fonction publique portant sur la
protection sociale des fonctionnaires il
prévoit je le rappelle la prise en
charge par l'état de 50 % de la
protection sociale complémentaire des
agents publics comme le président de la
république s'y était engagé dès 2019 ce
qui résout ainsi résorbe une injustice
puisque vous le savez pour les salariés
du privé
la mutuelle santé la complémentaire
santé est prise en charge à 50% par
l'employeur ça n'était pas le cas pour
les agents publics à la suite de cet
accord signé unanimement avec les
organisations syndicales ce sera
désormais désormais local c'est aussi
une démonstration que la fonction
publique peut avancer concrètement par
le dialogue social
amélie de montchalin ensuite présenté un
point sur les réformes prioritaires de
son ministère le premier axe concerne
l'égalité en matière d'égalité des
chances 1200 places en classe prépa
talents ont été ouvertes pour préparer
les étudiants boursiers aux concours de
la fonction publique dans les meilleures
conditions et avec des places réservées
en matière d'égalité femmes hommes
ensuite un plan spécifique a permis de
dépasser pour la première fois les 40%
de primes aux nominations sur les
emplois de direction de l'état nous
avons nommé plus de femmes à des postes
de très hautes responsabilités dans
notre administration qu'aucun autre
gouvernement auparavant le deuxième axe
concerne la qualité des services 95% des
services publics publié aujourd'hui
leurs résultats en toute transparence la
confiance des citoyens progressent
d'ailleurs de 5 points en un an pour
atteindre
77% signe des efforts réalisés pour
rapprocher les services publics des
français il pour assurer la continuité
des services publics pendant la crise
sanitaire le désir le dernier axe
concerne l'accessibilité
87% des démarches sont désormais
accessibles en ligne et nous visons 100%
en 2022 en effet un effort particulier
est menée depuis un an sur
l'accessibilité de ces demandes pour les
personnes en situation de handicap le
service france connect bénéficie lui
d'ores et déjà à plus de 3 millions
d'utilisateurs et nous avons évidemment
encore vu toute son utilité et tout son
impact ces derniers mois notamment dans
le cadre de la campagne de vaccination
nous avons rendu l'administration plus
simple et plus accessible c'était d'un
engagement et nous le tenons enfin la
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
a présenté une communication sur le
développement du programme france
service vous souvenez le programme
france service avait été annoncée par le
président de la république au lendemain
du grand débat national qui faisait
suite à la crise des gilet jaune c'était
précisément le 25 avril 2019 c'est un
programme qui marque le retour d'une
présence humaine de tous les services
publics essentiels dans tous les
territoires à moins de 30 minutes de
chaque français et hier le président de
la république était vous le savez en
déplacement en haute vienne à
saint-léonard-de-noblat précis très
précisément dans une maison france
service nous avons aujourd'hui atteint
l'objectif de 2000 maisons france
services labellisés en janvier 2022
grâce à plus de 1700 ouverture la
densification du réseau de même que
l'accroissement de la qualité du service
rendu ont permis de porter l'activité à
3,5 millions d'actes en 2021 c'est plus
du double qu'en 2020 plusieurs
expérimentations sont par ailleurs en
cours pour augmenter le nombre de
services proposés dans les maisons
france services dans des domaines aussi
variés que la télémédecine l'aide à la
jeunesse ou la justice voilà mesdames
messieurs ce que je pouvais vous dire de
ce conseil des ministres et je me tiens
à votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions et on démarre par agathe
sombre et ses ministres vous avez parlé
du coc vider les fêtes que vous
tiendriez le calendrier de desserrement
est ce que vous allez également bientôt
fixer des seuils ou des conditions qui
permettront de lever le pain vaccinale
est ce qu'on va bientôt être fixé sur
les levées de se passe d'abord ce que je
veux dire c'est que l'arrivée du pass
vaccinale a d'ores et déjà produit des
effets en termes de vaccination puisque
entre le moment où le pass daksi n'a été
annoncée le moment où il est rentré en
vigueur 1 millions de français
supplémentaires qu'ils n'avaient reçu
aucune injection est rentré dans un
schéma de un parcours de vaccination de
même qu'on avait vu un effet au moment
de l'annoncé de l'instauration du pass
sanitaires ou 13 millions français était
allé se faire vacciner après l'annnonce
du pass sanitaire il ya eu cet effet
ensuite l'arrivée du pass vaccinale nous
permet précisément de lever un certain
nombre de mesures qui restaient dans un
certain nombre de lieux notamment j'en
parlais à l'instant les jauges dans les
grands événements et puis des mesures
qui touchait les discothèques ou les
bars donc il est utile pour aller plus
loin dans la levée des restrictions
élevé ces dernières restrictions qui
étaient en cours dans ces lieux
maintenant on l'a toujours dit n'a pas
de fétichisme pour le pass vaccinale
pour aucun passe d'ailleurs est
évidemment dès qu'on pourra se
débarrasser de cet outil on s'en
débarrassera mais il n'empêche que cet
outil est celui qui l'a précédé le pass
sanitaire nous ont permis d'avoir une
situation nous avons maintenu notre pays
ouvert depuis des mois il ya des écoles
mais c'est le cas aussi je le rappelle
les restaurants des bars des cinémas des
théâtres des musées qui ont été fermés
dans beaucoup de pays européens cet
hiver beaucoup de pays européens cet
hiver il ya eu des confinement des
couvre-feux des fermetures
d'établissements grâce à nos outils
sanitaires y passe vaccinale désormais
on n'a pas eu ça en france maintenant
votre question c'est quelles seraient
les critères pour pouvoir
supprimer le pass vaccinale là dessus je
crois qu'on a été d'ores et déjà assez
clair c'est évidemment la situation à
l'hôpital qui sera juge de paix ce que
nous attendons c'est un retour à une
forme de normalité à l'hôpital nous
avons aujourd'hui un taux d'occupation
qui est très élevé du fait du coc vide
c'est évidemment retourner une situation
où nous n'aurons plus à procéder à des
déprogrammations où les opérations qui
avaient dû être des pauvres des
programmes et auront pu être
reprogrammée et donc c'est ça qui sera
vraiment notre boussole pour avancer
vers une éventuelle levée du pass
vaccinale dans les prochains mois
oui catherine dimanche à france
télévisions on note que de très
nombreuses contaminations touche d'abord
les enfants est ce que ça veut dire que
le gouvernement a fait le choix de
laisser filer le virus à l'école
vous savez que ce virus ce variant
mikron circule beaucoup partout compris
chez les enfants compris à l'école et
c'est pour ça qu'on a mis en place un
protocole sanitaire qui permet à la fois
de maintenir les écoles ouvertes et qui
permet en même temps précisément de ne
pas laisser filer le virus comme vous le
disiez quand on met en place des mesures
de non brassage entre des classes quand
on met en place des mesures qui visent à
ce que les enfants se croisent le moins
possible entre différentes classes quand
on met en place l'obligation du port du
masque pour des enfants à l'école quand
on met en place des obligations de test
assez nombreuses pour des enfants qui
sont qu'à contacter je ne crois pas
qu'on puisse dire qu'on laisse filer
l'épidémie tout cas je ne crois pas que
ce soit ressenti comme ça ni par les
enfants ni par leur famille ni par les
enseignants pour qui ces protocoles
entraîne beaucoup de contraintes moi
j'entends parfaitement que c'est
difficile que c'est une situation
difficile c'est pour ça qu'on est dur
adapter notre protocole vous l'avez vu à
plusieurs à plusieurs reprises mais non
précisée mandat une politique qui vise
d'un côté à lutter contre la circulation
du virus même si on sait que c'est très
difficile avec omicron parce qu'il est
très contagieux et en même temps là
c'est les écoles ouvertes à ce qu'on
sait que c'est ce qu'il ya de mieux pour
les enfants et ce à tous les acteurs
spécialistes des enfants le dise la
société française de pédiatrie le dit
aussi ils nord il n'y aurait rien de
pire que de fermer les écoles et donc
nous maintenons les écoles ouvertes
questions sur l'épidémie également si le
barça terre
on a déploré ces dernières 24 heures 400
morts à l'hôpital
c'est un record pour cette cinquième
vague vous citiez le président du
conseil scientifique jean françois
delfraissy qui dit aussi on aura une
vague d'hospitalisation très lourdes
jusqu'à la mi mars et on peut espérer
une amélioration au printemps le
calendrier de la levée des restrictions
intervient début février et mi février
en deux temps compte tenu de cette
situation est ce que ces sacs levée des
contraintes on n'intervient pas trop tôt
non vous savez cette levée des
contraintes a été
décidée précisément sur la base d'une
situation dont on constate en france et
de modélisation de prévisions qui font
état effectivement quand vous avez un
tel niveau de circulation du virus d'un
virus qui va continuer à circuler de
manière importante dans notre pays dans
les prochaines semaines et qui tienne
compte aussi de la réalité sanitaire
jeunesse constatons c'est à dire que ce
variant omicron à ce qu'il a une moindre
sévérité et aussi parce que nous avons
une très forte couverture vaccinale est
très loin d'avoir les mêmes effets sur
l'hôpital sur les services de
réanimation que ce que nous avions
constaté avec les précédents variant et
notamment le variant delta c'est donc en
responsabilité que nous avons décidé de
ce calendrier je rappelle qu'il restera
des mesures notamment le pass dax inall
ces dix entrées en vigueur et qui va -
entend continuer à s'appliquer
maintenant ce qui est certain c'est que
nous constatons beaucoup de
cas positifs encore chaque jour que nous
ne sommes pas encore au pic même si moi
j'écoute ce que disent les scientifiques
ce qu'ils indiquent c'est que nous
constatons depuis maintenant plus d'une
dizaine de jours une décrue épidémique
de la vague omicron dans la région qui
avait été frappé en premier par cette
vague c'est à dire la région
ile-de-france que cela peut laisser
augurer une décrue qui pourrait
intervenir assez rapidement sur
l'intégralité de notre pays même si on
voit dans un certain nombre de régions
ça continue à monter ce sont les régions
qui avait été frappée par la vague
omicron le plus tard je rappelle aussi
ce que nous constatons chez un certain
nombre de nos voisins européens avec
probablement un effet du sou mariant ba2
qui a été décrit est relayée par des
scientifiques mais nous voyons dans des
pays où il y avait eu une diminution une
réelle augmentation de la vague au micro
c'est le cas par exemple au danemark
constatons une vague omicron qui
continuent à montrer de manière très
forte dans un certain nombre de pays qui
nous entourent je pense notamment à
l'allemagne ou à d'autres pays on
constate qu au royaume uni il y avait
une décrue est très forte faut être très
prudent parce que c'est des chiffres des
tout derniers jours mais qui semble
montrer aussi en tout cas une
stabilisation peut-être une légère
remontée donc il ya évidemment une
prudence à avoir mais ceux qui
aujourd'hui constaté et assurer c'est
que nous a t'on pas le même impact sur
l'hôpital sur les réanimations que nous
constations avec les variants précédent
et c'est cet impact sur l'hôpital qui
nous est toujours conduit à prendre des
mesures ou à maintenir des mesures pour
ça qu'on peut donc adapter le calendrier
bonjour monsieur le ministre monsieur
carmen pour tf1 lci une petite question
sur ce qui se passe actuellement dans
les ehpad notamment cher pays où il ya
la publication de ce livre aujourd'hui
quelle est la position du gouvernement
est que peut faire l'état français face
à sa merci
d'abord ce que je veux dire c'est que
les révélations qui ont été faites dans
dans ce livre sont absolument révoltante
que vous avez le ventre noué en lisant
des choses pareilles et que si ces faits
sont avérés ils devront évidemment être
sanctionnée avec la plus grande sévérité
et donc nous avons d'ores et déjà
immédiatement pris un certain nombre de
décisions que je veux rappeler d'abord à
la demande d'olivier veyrat directeur
général d'orpea était convoquée par la
ministre déléguée chargée de l'autonomie
brigitte bourguignon qu'il rencontrera
avec qui il s'entretiendra dans les plus
brefs délais ensuite nous avons demandé
à l'agencé régionale de santé d'île de
france leur dernier rapport de contrôle
inopiné sur cet établissement celui dont
il est fait état et les suites qui avait
été donnée à ce rapport puisque je crois
qu'un contrôle de mémoire était
intervenue au cours de l'année 2018 et
qu'un rapport avait été remis en février
2019 et enfin nous envisageons sur la
base de ce rendez vous avec le directeur
général d'orpea sur la base des retours
que nous aurons de l' agence régionale
de santé sur ce contrôle est sûre ce
rapport de lancer une mission
d'inspection indépendante par
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales pour l'intégralité du groupe
orpea moi je veux rappeler et c'est là
aussi une parole importantes du
gouvernement que nos aînés méritent le
respect qu'ils méritent le meilleur et
qu'il est hors de question que de tels
agissements puisse être toléré dans
notre pays depuis le début du
quinquennat je veux rappeler aussi nous
sommes saisis de la question de nos
aînés avec le rappel 2 milliard cent
millions d'euros investis pour les ehpad
avec 10000 soignants supplémentaires
recrutés avec quarante mille
professionnels avec une loi qui permet
de mieux sanctionner la maltraitance en
ehpad et pour finir je veux avoir une
pensée pour tous les professionnels des
ehpad parce qu'on le sait dans leur
écrasante majorité dans leur quasi
totalité exercent leur mission avec
passion avec solidarité avec humanisme
avec sérieux et ces révélations ne
doivent pas jeter l'opprobre sur toute
une profession qui travaille travaille
parfois dans des conditions difficiles
mais qui le fait avec un très grand
sérieux et un très grand
professionnalisme et donc je vais aussi
avoir une un mot de solidarité pour eux
bonjour je rêvais de la sp aujourd'hui
plus de plus d'un tiers des salariés
d'edf sont en grève alors est ce que
vous comprenez les raisons de cette
grève et qu'est ce que vous pouvez dire
pour rassurer ses salariés on a déjà eu
l'occasion de s'exprimer sur sur ce
sujet là moi ce que je veux dire une
nouvelle fois c'est que le gouvernement
est aux côtés des salariés d'edf comme
nous sommes aux côtés de tous les
français il y a eu vous le savez il ya
un os supersonique des prix de l'énergie
qui nous a amenés à prendre un certain
nombre de décisions à faire des efforts
pour le pouvoir d'achat des français ça
vaut pour l'état comme pour les
entreprises dont l'état est actionnaire
majoritaire je me rappelais que l'état
était le premier à se mettre à
contribution puisqu'il a renoncé à 8
milliards d'euros de taxe intérieure sur
la consommation d'électricité et
qu'effectivement nous avons demandé à
edf de contribuer à cette réservation de
pouvoir d'achat en vendant plus
d'électricité à prix réduit pour
soutenir aussi le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages ce sont ces mesures qui nous
permettent je le dis d'éviter une
flambée des prix d'électricité en ce
début du mois de février si nous
n'avions pas pris ces mesures en ce
début du mois de février les français
auraient vu une augmentation de leur
facture d'électricité de 35 à 45% ça
veut dire que nous avons fait économiser
aux français en moyenne 300 à 400 euros
sur leur facture d'électricité qui le
recevront en février prochain par ces
mesures qui sont donc des mesures
extrêmement importante et je veux
ajouter que je crois qu edf le sait
parfaitement que l'état est évidemment
aux côtés d'edf que lorsque cette
entreprise est en difficulté à cause
deux tarifs bas elle est soutenue par
l'état qu'elle a reçu 10 milliards
d'euros d' aide à la capitalisation et
de renoncement aux dividendes depuis
2015 que comme l'a souligné le président
de la commission de régulation de
l'électricité en fin de semaine dernière
je crois il n'y a pas de raison de
s'inquiéter pour l'avenir d'edf jeu
rappelait aussi l'engagement du
président de la république du
gouvernement à relancer le programme
nucléaire dans notre pays qui vont
évidemment aider f sera tout à fait
partie prenante
bonjour vincent derosier de la radio rtl
je rebondis sur la question de mon
confrère juste avant sur la situation
des ehpad et orpea vous parler de
sanctions si les faits sont avérés ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
sachant que c'est un système privé
comment se fait-il par ailleurs qu'un
journaliste indépendant et pu mettre en
lumière tout ça dans un livre sachant
que l'état est censé faire des contrôles
réguliers que vous venez nous le dire un
rapport a été rendu en 2018 soit il ya
plus de trois ans est ce qu'il ya des
failles dans les contrôles dans la dans
la façon dont l'état intervient dans la
situation des ehpad sachant que vous
parler du sujet de dépendance depuis le
début du quinquennat comme une priorité
mais c'est précisément pour répondre à
cette question que nous avons demandé à
l'agencé régionale de santé
d'ile-de-france de nous communiquer le
rapport qui avait été constituée à
l'occasion du contrôle qui était
intervenu en 2018 sur cet établissement
que nous leur avons demandé de nous
indiquer les suites qui avait été donnée
à ce rapport et aux manquements
éventuels
situation grave éventuels qui avait été
constaté à l'occasion de ce rapport donc
justement ce que je suis en train de
vous dire ce que le gouvernement a dit
c'est que cet établissement avaient été
contrôlées par ce qu'il y à des
contrôles qui a des contrôles nombreux
et qu'il faut maintenant comprendre
qu'elle avait été le champ de ce
contrôle qu'est ce que ce contrôle avait
permis de révéler quels ont été les suit
sur ce que ce contrôle avait permis de
révéler et sur ce point là mes collègues
du gouvernement olivier ferrand et
brigitte bourguignon évidemment
reviendront devant vous pour vous dire
ce qu'il en est évidemment qu'ils auront
l'occasion de préciser s'il y a lieu de
prendre des sanctions qu'elles seront
assez sanctions j'espère moi aujourd'hui
de vous qu'est ce qu'on dit mais qu'est
ce qui est possible puisque sans frais a
déjà été sanctionné la bourse par
exemple mais à nouveau ce jeu l'étape je
laisse mes collègues du gouvernement il
ya par ailleurs je voulais d'une
rencontre qui interviendra avec les
dirigeants groupe je laisse mes
collègues du gouvernement communiqué
dans le cadre de ces rencontres qui vont
avoir lieu je veux vous dire mon tour
sur ce sujet vincent derosier le disait
le grand âge a été placé en tête des
priorités de ce gouvernement depuis cinq
ans pourtant la loi grand talent qui
étaient promises ne s'est pas faite elle
avait pour but justement de favoriser le
maintien à domicile qui est une des
réponses à ces dérives dans les ehpad
est-ce que l'abandon ou le report un
éventuel second mandat de cette loi
grand âge est un regret pour le
gouvernement et pour le président non
parce que nous avons pris des mesures
extrêmement ambitieux sur la question du
grand âge sans que cela se trouve dans
une loi grand âge mais dans les budgets
de la sécurité sociale par exemple et
dans un certain nombre de textes
j'abordais à l'instant la question des
recrutements la question du budget qui
ont augmenté fortement c'est le cas dans
un projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale 2 milliard cent
millions d'euros supplémentaires je
rappelle que c'est ce gouvernement et
cette majorité qui ont créé cette
historique la cinquième branche de la
sécurité sociale consacrée à l'autonomie
ça faisait des années qu'on en parlait
dans notre pays nous avons créé la
cinquième branche de la sécurité sociale
consacrée à l'autonomie prévu un
financement je le disais à l'instant je
rappelle que nous avons pris encore des
mesures à l'automne dernier sur la
question des aides à domicile là sur la
question du maintien à domicile on sait
que c'est essentiel notamment pour
lutter contre la précarité dans ce
secteur pour améliorer la rémunération
des personnes qui interviennent au
domicile des personnes âgées dépendantes
en lien évidemment avec les départements
et avec les associations cas des mesures
budgétaires très fortes qui ont été
prises aussi pour relever le plancher de
rémunération pour les aides à domicile
vous voyez il ya toute cette politique
cohérent ce qu'ils étaient menés depuis
2010 est évidemment que sur laquelle il
faut continuer à avancer
bonjour le seigneur pour ses news une
question sur la campagne présidentielle
quand même on dit que le président
bientôt candidat pourrait ne pas vouloir
faire des débats avec les autres les
autres candidats est-ce que ça pose pas
un problème démocratique de ne pas voir
le président candidat face à ses
adversaires et en quelqu'un est ce que
vous en tant que porte parole du
gouvernement vous pourriez par exemple
le remplacer voilà enfin vous savez que
j'ai pour habitude de ne jamais répondre
aux questions qui ont trait aux
campagnes électorales quelles qu'elles
soient ou non il y avait des questions
sur la campagne des régionales je n'ai
pas répondu non plus sur la campagne des
présidentielles voilà je suis ici dans
mon rôle institutionnel de porte parole
du gouvernement en sortie du conseil des
ministres à l'elysée je considère que
c'est pas le lieu pour parler des sujets
de campagne mais je pense que ne vous a
pas échappé que je fais régulièrement
des interventions dans les médias quand
vous m'invitez que ça vous arrive de me
poser des questions sur ces sujets là et
que ça m'arrive aussi de répondre assez
souvent donc je pense que j'aurai
l'occasion de m'exprimer sur toutes ces
questions la prochaine mais en dehors du
cas d'emmanuel mac os que ce serait pas
un problème démocratique de ne pas voir
maintenant c'est à nous de chercher à me
casser habile de chercher à me faire
répondre indirectement à des questions
sur sur la campagne sur les débats
éventuels qui auront lieu mais encore
une fois c'est pas le lieu pour moi de
m'exprimer sur ce sujet vous nous avez
donné les bottes
bonjour à lisbonne de bloomberg news ce
que vous estimez que le gouvernement n'a
aucune responsabilité dans la faillite
des systèmes de surveillance qui ont
conduit à ce scandale chez leur père
encore une fois en je vous dis que
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un moment
de clarifications sur des procédures qui
ont été engagés sur des contrôles qui
ont eu lieu sur un établissement dont
nous avons aujourd'hui un livre qui fait
état de faits extrêmement graves et donc
il ya une moment de clarification qui
est engagée sur quelle avait été la
nature du contrôle quels ont été les
manquements qui ont été relevés dans le
cadre de ce contrôle et quels ont été
les suites qui ont été donnés à se
contrôler à ce rapport je pourrais
répondre
donc la réponse sera dans les
conclusions que nous tirerons des
retours que nous aurons du contrôle qui
a eu lieu et des procédures éventuels
qui ont été engagées ensuite je peux pas
vous répondre aujourd'hui à cette
question là puisque précisément comme
les différents l'a dit hier nous sommes
dans ce moment de clarification sur ce
sujet
une question internationale est ce que
le gouvernement ou l'elysée eu des
contacts avec les militaires qui ont
pris le pouvoir au burkina faso et on a
vu hier des images que quelques
manifestants brandissant à ouagadougou
des drapeaux russe alors est ce que vous
craignez ou es ce que vous avez des
informations sur une possible un
possible soutien de moscou aux
putschistes comme comme ça a pu avoir
lieu par simple au mali sur le dernier
point je dispose pas de de l'information
précise sur ce sujet là moi je veux dire
que le président de la république a été
très ferme hier dans sa condamnation du
coup d'état militaire au burkina faso
rejoignant a d'ailleurs la position de
la cedeao qui s'est exprimé aussi
fortement sur ce sujet là c'est bien sûr
une situation qui est
préoccupante parce que ce type de
déstabilisation à démocratique d'un pays
nous préoccupent particulièrement alors
que nous ton avec détermination contre
le terrorisme dans la région je veux
dire que nous travaillons étroitement
avec nos partenaires pour l'intérêt de
la population locale mais aussi plus
largement pour préserver et pour
poursuivre nos efforts de sécurisation
et développement de la région pour
répondre à votre question sur les
interlocuteurs etc je veux dire qu'on
échange avec la cedeao qui elle-même
évidemment intervient sur ce sujet là
que la cedeao doit se réunir très
prochainement sur ce sujet et que ce que
nous attendons nous s'agissant de la
france c'est un calendrier de retour à
l'ordre constitutionnel au burkina faso
sylvie corbet satiété de presse
également une question internationale
le président américain joe biden menace
désormais poutine lui-même de sanction
si jamais il devait y avoir une action
de la russie en ukraine
on sait que le président macron doit
s'entretenir avec poutine justement
vendredi matin qu'est-ce que quel rôle
joue la france dans cette crise et
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre de cet
appel avec poutine
il ya une situation et un contexte tendu
sur ce dossier
craignant
vous savez qu'il ya eu un certain nombre
de rencontres des échanges qui ont eu
lieu que le président de la république a
eu l'occasion de s'exprimer encore hier
avant son échange et sa réunion avec le
chancelier allemand olaf scholz qu'elle
aime répondre à des questions sur ce
sujet là pour répondre à votre question
sur le rôle de la france parce que je
veux dire c'est que le président de la
république est au coeur des efforts qui
sont engagées pour la désescalade qui
s'entretiendra à cette fin vous l'avez
dit avec les président poutine aisée
dans ce qui dans les tout prochains
jours que se tient aujourd'hui même à
paris une réunion en format normandie
des conseillers diplomatiques des quatre
chefs d'état des pays qui participent à
ce format normandie que jean yves le
drian présidait lundi à bruxelles une
réunion du conseil des ministres des
affaires des affaires étrangères de
l'union européenne qui a permis de
parvenir à une position commune forte
sur ce sujet là donc voyez bien que la
france elle est au coeur des efforts qui
sont menées pour la désescalade on avait
demandé très précisément les objectifs
de l'échangé téléphonique qui
interviendra entre le président macron
le président poutine vendredi matin il
ya d'abord un objectif de poursuite du
dialogue évidemment nous avons toujours
été clairs sur le fait qu'il fallait
poursuivre le dialogue qui est
évidemment des conditions de la
désescalade qui n'empêche pas évidemment
de travailler aussi à des sanctions
dissuasives ce que nous faisons dans un
cadre européen ce que nous faisons être
nos partenaires américains ce que nous
faisons aussi dans le cadre de l'otan
pour être clair sur le fait qu'il y
aurait des conséquences massive et un
coup sévère pour la russie s'il y avait
une nouvelle incursion sur le territoire
ukrainien et le deuxième ce premier
objectif c'est la poursuite du dialogue
et le deuxième objectif de cet échange
c'est de pousser la russie a clarifié sa
position est la finalité des manoeuvres
engagées sur ce sujet là
s'il n'y a pas d'autres questions
je vous remercie et je vous dis à la
semaine prochaine